la restauration et l'hôtellerie mise à
mal par la crise sanitaire en france les
salariés intermittente ce secteur ont
mené une action coup de poing ce matin à
paris ils réclament un plan d'urgence
pour leur profession et s'oppose à la
réforme de l'assurance chômage en cause
ils peuvent bénéficier des mesures d'
aides prévues par l'état et faute
d'avoir pu travailler
nombreux sont ceux qui n'ont pas droit à
des indemnités de chômage
leur manifestation simulait une marche
funèbre depuis l'assemblée nationale
jusqu'à la place de la concorde
une délégation devrait être reçue
prochainement par muriel pénicaud
la ministre du travail et coûté le
gouvernement a mis en place des mesures
d'urgence chose qui est bien depuis le
début du confinement depuis la crise
sanitaire
c'est bien on félicite la chose mais en
parallèle il a laissé à la marche plus
de deux millions de personnes qui sont
dans l'intermittence de l'emploi qu'on
appelle plus communément les extras de
l'hôtellerie restauration événementielle
et autres et qui n'ont aucune mesure
d'urgence
tout le monde a été sauvé par un chômage
partiel et c'est pas le cas pour nous
parce que certains dépendent d'un
certain nombre d'heures par rapport au
premier volet de la réfondation chômage
quelque 910 heures n'ayant pas les airs
pas droit au chômage
simplement et donc après on demande les
minima sociaux dans certains cas on peut
avoir le rsa mais c'est pas le cas de
tout le monde
voilà et est ce que le rsa c'est un plan
d'urgence pour vivre ça c'est une
problématique ou qu'elle le gouvernement
ne répond pas mais quand même on
travaille en intermittence de l'emploi
toute l'année depuis des années au plus
haut sommet de l'état à l'elysée raison
bastad les ministères et administrations
et c'est notre statut qui est comme ça
hein c'est un cdi on peut pas en avoir 1
parce que ça la manifestation
tout le personnel extra qui dépendent
l'événementiel se retrouvent
de plus en plus dans une prise dans une
précarité extrême on demande
l'annulation de cette réforme là et que
tous les extras maître d'hôtel de la
restauration qui dépendent de
l'événementiel tout comme les loups tous
les intermittents du spectacle
reprennent se retrouve dans le régime
intermittent auquel nous avons dans
lequel nous étions jusqu'en 2014
[Musique]